823 1567 c'est notre chiffre du jour il
s'agit du nombre de personnes vaccinées
contre le coc vide en france selon le
ministère de la santé au 21 janvier 28
1877 habitants de notre région déjà reçu
au moins une dose du vaccin
pourtant la machine commence à se
gripper les réservations sont plus
possibles pour se faire vacciner que ce
soit en indre et loire ou en loir et
cher à leurs problèmes de logistique ou
manque de vaccins ont fait le point à
amboise avec florent clavel depuis lundi
amboise 150 personnes ont été vaccinées
ensuite viennent les chanceux qui ont pu
obtenir un rendez-vous dans les
prochaines semaines et les autres
j'essaye de prendre rendez vous et je
n'y arrive pas c'est à dire c'est à dire
qu'on appelant les sites qui existent
sont préconisées on me dit que c'est
clara qui feront me répondra
ultérieurement car à des dates qui se
débloqueront mais pour l'instant tout
est plat tous les créneaux sont pleins
et pourtant cet après midi le centre de
vaccination de la ville ne vaccine à
porte close
au grand désarroi de viviane soixante
dix huit ans j'ai fait un rendez vous
croyant avoir de rendez vous ou pour mon
mari et pour moi en définitive j'ai la
confirmation que pourra donc je voulais
savoir si je pouvais avoir le deuxième
mais c'est fermé
je suis plus que perdu parce que tout
est fermé dont je sais pas ce qu'il faut
faire et sur internet on n'arrive pas à
les joindre
en fait la ville gère l'ouverture du
centre en fonction des livraisons de
vaccins et pour l'instant elle ne
dépasse pas les 150 doses par semaine
mais le maire refuse d'accabler l'état
au contraire qu'au début ça se passe
avec un nombre de doses pas trop
important ça permet aussi au centre de
se mettre en ordre de marche
ça n'est pas dans notre vocation
habituel d'avoir des centres de
vaccination donc il faut aussi que la
coordination se fasse pour l'instant
aucune accélération de la vaccination
des annonces
et en bois et ses alentours environ 3500
seniors de plus de 75 ans doivent
recevoir une injection